BAU BAU!
It was not our fault!
Okay, something was weird!
The hydraulics were leaking!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua!
It's time for... One more time!
One more time, okay?
Give us a moment.
Hello BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we are your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Perfect way to start off the week!
Yo!
A little bit of a funny start, but thank you Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today for our 138th episode!
Yeah!
FUWAMOCO!
Look at what's going on FUWAMOCO-chan!
I think things broke.
Nothing to lead to, Ruffians.
We just have to hold on to what we have!
FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, do you remember this was the place that you used to... There, there, there!
That's the BAU BAU!
Yeah!
Yeah, you know, I feel like recently I always say let's BAU BAU!
Ruffians are just going hashtag #still.
Do you not want us to say BAU BAU anymore?
Hashtag!
Let's BAU BAU together, okay, Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
Wow, we've already had a bit of a funny start today, Moco-chan.
Just how silly are things gonna get?
I don't know.
BAU BAU!
Wow, it's been a long day!
Another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Hi!
Moco-chan.
What do we have?
What?
Have another Perroccino.
I thought we were gonna start with something else, you know.
More exciting news.
No.
Wow, Ruffians!
Pero Sighting.
I wasn't prepared for this!
These happen.
Sometimes you have to not be prepared.
Hi!
BAU BAU.
Pero, Pero's at the pop-up store.
He just popped up.
Just popped up.
Oh my gosh.
He could not pop up.
What's he doing there with our merch store?
Is he hiding over there?
Is he pero-pero-ing it?
Pero-pero-ing it?
Maybe, you know, maybe he's just helping out.
Restocking it.
You know.
Or maybe...
He's jealous.
They're jealous.
Maybe this is one of his ways to get taken home by the Ruffians.
Don't fall for it, okay?
Ruffians, okay!
You know the petapushies!
They still haven't been released yet!
Okay, don't get confused!
Don't be mistaken, okay?
Just wait a little bit longer, okay?
Not in race!
No!
Yeah, I just made a restock or something whatever.
Yeah, maybe, uh... How about instead you try out one of the FUWAMOCO pillows up there?
Why?
What's softer?
No bones inside.
No bones and then you know no calamities will befall you either, won't they?
Open!
You want to copy a real life Pero, not a plushie?
Right
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
While we announced last week, we announced the release of Advent's very special horror voice drama, Palemonte Voice!
BAU BAU!
You know, last year, I think it was one of the first things we did after Advent's debut as a unit.
The first thing we did was we released our first horror drama which was The Manor.
The Manor, did you hear it?
I think it's still on sale so you know if you're maybe a new Adventrix and you want to check it out you can check it out still.
Yeah but I know we were really nervous you know it's our first kind of thing but you know so many Adventrix and Ruffians really loved it.
So this year we released a brand new one and that one is
Hale Montereau is here!
But this time, it is extra long.
Extra long, it's a full, well not quite a full, but almost a full hour long drama.
Hour long.
Yeah, and both fans can get the full set of both acts.
I'm pretty sure you want to get both acts because it's the story.
It's kind of like just going to the first half of the movie or just seeing how
The end half of the movie.
You probably want both.
Probably want both.
But if you get the full set, it comes with this key visual.
Here is a wallpaper.
And then also supplemental character settings and information you know.
That's just how detailed, how fleshed out the world is and everything.
It is very intense.
Yeah, it's basically a movie.
Basically.
Yeah, an audio novel.
Audio.
Audio novel.
The script must have been long.
Wow!
You can also get the script, I believe.
Yeah, the script comes with it.
It was 71 pages!
Yeah, it is a very full horror voice drama.
But!
Wow, you probably are kind of curious.
What is Palais Montrose?
What exactly is this story?
What is the story?
Wow, the story goes as follows.
The Palais Montrose wants parties, crown jewels, and home to L.M.
Montrose.
The greatest diva alive now stands as a haunting reminder of her mysterious disappearance.
One fateful night, a cash- What a fateful night!
A cash dissembles.
An orphan girl in search of her birth boy, Biboo.
A property manager intent on restoring the reputation of the venue.
If you want to talk to the manager, you have to talk to Mococo.
An esteemed scientist on a crusade against the supernatural.
That sounds like Fuwawa-han.
No supernatural never.
And an up-and-coming diva, looking for answers, seeking justice.
Nerissa!
Although I think she's already a big diva.
Though the four carry the torch of hope and the tools of science, nothing can prepare them for what hides in the shadow of this place.
And of course Shiori is our faithful.
She's our kind of story, our storyteller.
FUWAMOCO Storyteller.
Please check it out, FUWAMOCO fans!
It was really, really fun.
A very different experience than you know.
Like we mentioned, I played the young scientist Celeste.
And Moco-chan, you're the new manager pilot in Montreal, Celeste.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Celeste!
I'm not Mococo, I'm Celeste!
Yeah.
And together we are Celeste Celeste.
Yo, but Ruffians, can you imagine Fuwawa as a scientist?
Well, you do have to imagine.
You can go with it.
Right.
Yeah, except you know, not only am I a scientist, but I'm a very obnoxious scientist.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
I'm the manager!
Any complaints?
It's a very interesting voice genre.
You know we all take on very new roles, different characters.
So we hope that you'll check it out all for yourself.
And you know, if the manner is still available then you can listen to the manner.
Oh, this was one year ago and this is now.
Oh, they've improved this much.
Maybe, oh, they haven't improved at all.
It's up to you.
I don't think they've improved a little bit at least.
But both stories in the Palais Montrose and the Manor are different stories, so you don't have to listen to the one last year to enjoy the one this year.
BAU BAU!
That was a lot of fun.
But speaking of fun!
I think the Ruffians have been having a lot of fun at Round1!
Ruffians!
I know you've probably been getting those paws up and going for a walk to Round1 hut!
Together with other hololive listeners too!
And you know we know that many Round1 locations now have their plushies in!
And you know some others don't have to get them yet!
It seems like a lot of the locations also have started to run out of plushies.
Yeah.
As you know, these plushies are very special right now.
The Round1 hololive collab is happening in Japan and the US.
But these ones, the plushies are limited to the US.
Yeah.
Yeah, all the JP Ruffians.
We couldn't get Fuwawa, she was gone already.
I see a lot of Ruffians being like, Fuwawa just doesn't want to go out of the machine.
Are you at the karaoke?
Be careful FUWAMOCO!
It's tricky!
Maybe you have to check back, you know?
But you know, all of them seem to be sort of...
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Is this an ad?
It is not an ad!
We're just excited to see you have fun together, okay?
You know, I've heard that some Ruffians are BAU BAUing and the employees are BAU BAU BAUing.
We're just happy, okay?
Please Ruffians, we hope that you have a lot of fun around us.
It just makes us really happy.
And please save us from the machines too, okay?
We trapped her!
Especially on the middle-sized FUWAMOCO plushies!
It seems difficult.
You know there's a floating head FUWAMOCO, the Mocoball.
Mocoball!
I've seen it!
That you can put onto your bags or stairs.
And then there's the middle-sized plushie.
The one that you can take around with you nice and easy.
That's the hardest one to get, so don't let your guard down.
And then the big, big lying down FUWAMOCO!
It seems like he's the easiest.
Yeah.
And also, you're not the easiest to hug, too.
Yeah, yukkuri FUWAMOCO.
That's right.
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Wow, you might have missed it.
It wasn't on our channel.
It wasn't on our schedule.
But the other day, yesterday, we had a special off club.
Our first off club with AZKi-senpai and Iroha-senpai over on Iroha-senpai's channel.
And Iroha-senpai's house too.
It was a lot of fun!
Maybe looking at the thumbnail here, it's hard to understand.
We did something a little bit different.
It was a special collab where Iroha-senpaishi made her famous cookies for us.
But not just normal cookies.
Not normal cookies, it can't be normal, huh?
Yeah, cookies in the shape of different perfections of Japan.
And then we had a battle!
Yes, just like this!
You know, a battle between FUWAMOCO.
This time we're competing.
I thought we were a team for some reason.
But as not to see who can eat as many cookies as possible, first just looking at the shapes, we have to be able to tell which perfection of Japan it is.
Right?
How do you think you would do, Ruffian 5?
You got two guesses!
FUWAMOCO!
FWMCMORNING.
Yes!
How many did you eat?
We ate so many we are getting full!
They were delicious!
We were getting them all right!
All right!
You know I was.
Moco-chan, that's just because your hand was faster!
I didn't want to say, but maybe Azuki-sensei... No, no, no!
No!
She was being very fair, okay?
I was faster.
BAU BAU!
Yes.
We did pretty well!
We did have some hints here and there.
But TP-senpai, you know, they had to get even more hints before.
And I think there's even perfections that just, I don't know.
But we got through all of them!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
Udon.
Yadon.
Slowpoke!
That was Kagawa!
So we're able to eat quite a bit of cookies!
I think the biggest shock though was when AZKi-senpai, when she was like, oh this perfection's known for its mikan oranges and it wasn't Ehime!
It was not Ehime.
It was Hyougoken.
Was it Hyougo?
Was it Wakayama?
No, Hyougoken.
Ah, Hyougoken.
Ramen.
Ume.
Ume and Mikan.
Wakayama-ken was just really hard, right?
Yeah.
But cookies and frosting!
Oh, we did some mountains on them too, and little faces.
That would be really complicated.
AZKi-senpai and Iroha-senpai worked really hard on the cookies.
They did, you know!
We just showed up to Iroha-senpai's house.
I feel bad, but you showed up with, I'm gonna guess and eat cookies, huh?
Right!
And she was like, ah, there's even eggs!
These ones just came out of the oven!
Right!
We wanna eat them, they just came out of the oven, so don't burn your mouth, okay?
We're just there like, okay, we're just gonna guess the shapes of the cookies.
But it was so much fun, you know?
Just not being able to have fun
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
But AZKi-senpai and Iroha-senpai were both pretty and French.
This seems by our knowledge of Japan.
I'm kind of surprised.
I didn't think you'd do very well.
But it's so hard!
Ruffians, do you think you could do this?
Maybe if it was like the states of America?
Can you tell the states of America if they were cookies?
Yeah, maybe!
Nope.
Maybe.
Well, you could give it a shot, too!
It's certainly not easy to bake cookies just as beautiful as this, though.
Do your best!
You know how Senpai did an amazing job!
Ruffians, check it out!
Ruffians, if you want to see who wins, you'll have to find out.
BAU BAU!
And, wow, you know FUWAMOCO's beloved mama, Icomochi-mama!
Icomochi-mama has been up to so many exciting things recently!
Right now, she's having a special exhibition for her artwork called "Candy Blue"!
The works are all based off of fairy tales!
They're really, really cute too!
Super duper cute!
Icomochi-mama!
She was even doing signatures at the exhibition too!
Right now it's happening at Hello Culture 4 at the ILLUST GALLERY TOLALA in Umeda!
So not in Tokyo!
Actually, tomorrow is the last day!
I think you have until 5pm.
So, you know, Ruffians, if you're in the area, maybe you can pop in and check it out.
You know, there's a bunch of things going on, lots to see, and also Icomochi-mama released a special book of some of the illustrations featured at this exhibition.
Our boys are here!
Icomochi-mama!
Yeah, we really love Icomochi-mama's works.
But you know, not just has Icomochi-mama been busy with this exhibition, but she's also going to be having a table at the upcoming holocall!
A hololive only doujinshi event that's happening at the very beginning of November on the 10th!
Icomochi-mama!
She'll have some unofficial FUWAMOCO fanworks that she'll be selling there too.
And then, also, look!
She'll have this super cute brand new clear poster!
It's so cute!
Right!
I feel like she'll give me Onyanko Cup by then.
As expected of Icomochi-mama!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Thank you Icomochi-mama!
BAU BAU!
Wow!
Exciting news, Ruffians!
Elizabeth?
Elizabeth of Justice.
She just had a special announcement!
But!
Elizabeth's going to be releasing a cover of The Beatles' Blackbird on Music Streaming Services very soon!
It's gonna be coming out on the 30th at 9AM GMT!
You know, it's made
You know hololive members, they release covers a lot, right?
But!
This is actually really big, right?
We usually were not able to archive, you know, doing our utawaku, our karaoke streams, our western music.
This is so big!
Right, but this is the Beatles!
Yes!
Right, it's huge!
Right, but you know this is something very new, so we hope that you'll support us.
With this you'll listen to lots and lots.
You know, if we could really cover the western music.
What would you want to hear, Ruffians?
It's been a long time since we've done a... Rock n' Roar Party?
Sabotage!
Aba!
Michael Jackson!
Kawamata!
Oh, crazy vlog!
Wow, it seems like Ruffians have lots of ideas huh!
Love for you so far, Elizabeth!
I'm really excited to listen to it!
It's gonna be so nice!
October 30th, 9am.
Still a little ways away.
9am GMT.
I'm gonna guess it's not like the 29th.
Is this song particularly Halloween-y?
Or is it?
I don't know this song.
I'm sure it's on a MacBook.
Have a Halloween song.
But I don't know.
I don't really know the Beatles either.
Congratulations Elizabeth!
And please check it out on Spotify and other music streaming services soon.
Okay, Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
I didn't know the beginning of Justice!
Halloween!
Well, Justice has something coming up very soon!
Ruffians would invite you to hear!
Yeah, cause you're invited!
You're invited, Ruffians!
You always are.
You might have seen it on our schedule too, but Justice is going to be having a Haunted Mansion investigation.
And it's going to be happening in VRChat!
And of course, FUWAMOCO, we're gonna go too!
It's a trap.
It's not a trap.
They need our help.
It's an investigation, Ruffians.
Why do you think it's a trap?
They're not investigating us.
They're investigating the Haunted Mansion.
They need the help of the fellow hololive members.
They want our help.
Okay.
You know, but it's a haunted mansion investigation.
Yeah.
Not a spooky jumpscare mansion.
Right.
Just haunted, you know.
Maybe DJ will be like... Or something, right?
Yeah.
It's just a cute one, right?
The C.I.A.
will have cobwebs all around and be like... Right?
Right?
Yeah.
That's what I mean.
Ruffians, why are you making that face?
Why?
I'm sure it'll be very fun, very spooky, also cute, not so scary.
Please join us in justice for some Halloween fun, okay?
In the haunted investigation.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Let's check out our Doggie of the Day today!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... Lilli!
Oh, you know Lilli.
Lilli's a little bit of an older girl who's also not a Fuwawa.
She's a Chihuahua!
BAU BAU!
She is a Chihuahua.
She's Lilli!
Moco-chan, how does Lilli BAU BAU?
BAU BAU.
Cute!
Are you dreaming, Lilli?
No.
No?
Let's just you do your best BAU BAUs!
Yes!
Oh!
Okay.
I thought Lilli was dreaming.
No.
Lilli, you know!
Lilli's a very cute grandma!
Who also appreciates the fluff despite not being a Lola.
Not a Lola!
A chihuahua that likes to fluff.
You know we get along despite the differences, right?
She's super cute and you know we wish her lots of comfy, fluffy nubs and even more head pads too!
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, let's take a look at where you've been going for walks recently, huh?
Today, I went on a walk.
Where did we go?
We have...
Oh!
Pumpkin!
Pumpkin patch!
We went to the pumpkin patch together with you!
We're so happy that we could come along!
What kind of pumpkin did you pick out?
Isn't it funny?
I was thinking, what looks rounder, huh?
Pumpkins, huh?
FUWAMOCO.
Huh?
They both look very round.
Oh!
But I don't want the Ruffians carving us.
No!
Don't carve us!
We are supposed to stay exactly as we are!
Yeah!
Well, you know, hopefully you got a pumpkin that's bigger than us!
Because otherwise it might be a little bit hard to carve.
Yeah, but hopefully you have a bunch of Halloween fun decorating it or carving it!
I wonder what you're gonna carve it into, you know?
FUWAMOCO Team Pumpkins!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Today's Question of the Day is...
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
We know your favorite place in the world is Mister Donut in Akihabara.
Can you tell us the story behind it?
What makes it so special to you?
Is it the food?
The location?
Or both?
It's a good question!
You know, of course.
We really love Akihabara so so much!
It's just so much fun!
You know, and naturally after spending
A really fun day of doing a bunch of different things, you know.
Maybe enjoying aisle performances, shopping, maid cafes, you know, some arcades.
You shouldn't need a place to just take it easy.
Right, and there's not really that many of those places in Akihabara.
But Akihabara means to us that place for us.
Yeah, it means relaxation.
And not only that. You know, pon-de-rings of course are our absolute favorite.
But it's really comfy, you know?
It's just the perfect place!
You can go up to the second floor and watch people on the main street from the window and just watch Akihabara and the seasons change and everything, you know?
And you know, even though Akihabara has changed a lot throughout the years, Mister Donut Akihabara, it's always been there!
It's been there, you know?
Just dependable, comfy.
Like your home, you know?
So that's why.
It was our favorite, right?
You know, our comfy home and our favorite town ever, Akihabara!
You know, and that's also why that as soon as we got to Japan, you know, early in the year, we wanted to have that first tour!
And so, but, you know, now this week, we have to say goodbye to that, to Akihabara.
We missed it so much.
Yeah.
So let's end it off with a big BAU BAU!
Goodbye Goodbye Akiba Mistoshi Mocchi Ruffians!
I wish that you could've gone to Ruffians more.
But thank you more for you!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
A big thank you for all your submissions!
Yes!
Thank you for always remembering the hashtag too!
#FWMCMORNING!
If you have a doggy of a day, maybe you spotted a parrot, or you have a question, or you know you went on a walk and it was an exceptionally good walk, please let us know with that hashtag!
You know FWMC MORNING at the end of the week is gonna be.
Thank you so much BAU BAU!
Well, let's take a look at our schedule here to find out what's the next stream coming up.
We have our schedule!
Next, with the Doggy Pack, we're going to be doing a once-along of a famous Japanese horror movie.
We're going to be watching Dark Water.
I see more FUWAMOCO.
That's really scary.
Really scary.
We just played Visage.
Moco-chan, we're tough demon dogs.
We can do this, you know.
It's like an atmospheric scary.
I don't know.
I'm gonna be ready for it.
It's gonna be fine Moco-chan with the Ruffians, you know.
Don't hold our paws.
Bring a little bit more spookiness into the Halloween season.
And then on Wednesday we have another FUWAMOCO Morning.
And then our Goodbye Akiba Misto stream.
Yeah, please wait for it!
We know it's a bit of a strange time.
It's not really Wednesday, it's sort of Thursday.
It starts at midnight PT, so just as it becomes Thursday.
But we're spending the very last hour of Akiba Misto Open all together, so let's say goodbye to it then.
Justice's Haunted Investigation.
3D Trick or Treating with your Ruffians.
FUWAMOCO Morning before hibernation.
Donkey Kong Country 2.
And then on Saturday, we're gonna be continuing our Minecraft journey!
It's been a while, but if you're a Minecraft pro, or even if you just know a little bit of Minecraft, you can probably help us.
And we very appreciated trying to exist in the world of Minecraft without exceeding necessary.
Please join us, Ruffians!
I don't even remember how, do we?
We'll have to find out!
BAU BAU!
And for the Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is... It's BAU BAU Blackbird!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Patience Zero!
BAU BAU!
Ex-Human Boy!
Chaos!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!